Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.
How are you guys doing? And I am joined
once again
>> by someone who's not on the Epstein
file. [laughter]
>> You know, somebody put out a message
going, "At this point, we just need to
be asking who's not on the list."
>> Yes.
>> Because bloody every one of these guys
is on the list and they've been doing
some mad stuff.
>> Absolutely. I mean, one of the people
that have been on the list is the
>> your best friend, isn't it?
>> The electric car salesman. [laughter]
Actually, his name is Elon Musk. Uh,
whose father is an incestuous man, as we
know, he's dealt with his stepdaughter
in a manner that is unbefitting and
unbecoming of any human being. Um, and
his son is a transgender. And of course,
dysfunction, sexual dysfunction runs in
the family because this one here,
madness,
>> he wanted to let loose and go wild on
the island where the underage were being
uh abused. You know, the biggest irony
of all, it was because of him, he
reignited this whole grooming debate in
the UK as well.
>> He's the bastard that he's the one that
came out and for for months on end,
>> you know what I mean,
>> was the was the torchbearer for
anti-Islamic grooming gang as he called
it. And he was involved
>> in the biggest gang on [laughter] the
planet.
>> Yeah. For the last 100 years.
>> Absolutely.
>> We didn't intend to make that
synchronized. That just happened. It's
actually Wow. Great minds. great minds
and your mind as how that happened.
[laughter]
>> But look, I mean it's uh last week on
Twitter I was being attacked
>> and this week on Twitter I'm doing the
attacking.
>> You're doing the [laughter] attacking?
Yeah.
>> Look at the nisam. You know,
>> I made dua against him last week. This
bastard.
>> Clearly, I knew that this is the man
>> who um Subhan Allah. Like, you know,
he's the one who altered the algorithm.
Yeah.
>> To make it like that. But there was
other things on the
>> EP. He's he's manipulated the algorithm
to such a degree that there are entire
countries thinking how on earth and what
on earth do we do
>> to take away his influence. The UK has
been affected
>> very profoundly because he's been
clearly funding, supporting, promoting
Tommy Robinson.
>> He has and
>> and then Tommy Robinson in turn has been
promoting certain people at Speaker's
Corner. Well, he's cheap and at any
price according to um
>> Yeah,
>> according to him. According to the
Epstein files.
>> Absolutely.
>> Cheap and at any price. Like a scanger.
>> Yeah. Epstein and Steve Bannon. They
were talking with each other.
>> A prostitute actually.
>> Well,
>> cheap and at any price.
>> Yes. And he's supposed to be what what
did they say?
>> The backbone.
>> He's the backbone. He's the chav escort
services for the [laughter]
for the elites. The chav escort
services. That's what he was doing. He's
he's he's uh any price. You know, I'm
highest bidder,
>> a person with no principles. But it
shows you all of these peoples are on
the Epstein files.
>> I promise you,
actually, what's hidden is more.
>> You know, there's going to be more stuff
that's going to be revealed about these
people. Videos are going to come out.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, uh, pictures are going to come
out. We've already seen, uh, Elon Musk's
Cyber Truck type body. [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Don't Don't be surprised if we see it
again. Yeah.
>> You know, and now he's he's scrambling
all over the place on on Twitter and
social media on his own platform.
>> Yeah.
>> On his own platform.
>> It's like, you know, there's a few of
these guys that they have had a very
dodgy past and they are trying to find
shelter with the far right, the
rightwing. One example, Donald Trump.
>> Yes.
>> You saw him do a complete U-turn and try
to acquies to the far right. Russell
Brand.
>> Mhm.
>> He acquiesed on the on the files.
>> I I don't know. I don't know. But with
him,
>> well, he has his own controversies.
>> He had his own controversies and you
know, they came out in the UK media. But
>> the far right is a great place for
people with sexual misconduct
allegations or who have actually
perpetrated sexual misconduct. It's the
only it's a safe haven for that.
>> And then in turn for them, the safe
haven is Tel Aviv.
>> The far right is the [laughter]
>> the far right is a grooming gang.
It has just and that's the irony of the
mother of all ironies is that the far
right the greatest proponents and the
loudest voices of the far right
>> have become recognized now as linked to
associated with Jeffrey Epstein and I
always wonder why didn't I call him a
Jewish grooming gang or a trafficker he
a Jewish trafficker you know he was of
Jewish
>> ancestry he I think was a Jew
religiously you know his friend was a
Jew that Gain Maxwell as well wasn't you
Yeah, she's Jewish. Even if you go on
the Epstein files and you look for the
word or goyam, it's it's everyday
vernacular um in in the Epstein files.
And even when you've got the Israelis
themselves, there's a former
intelligence Israeli intelligence
officer called Ari Berry um Minash.
>> Yes.
>> He admitted it as well. He's like, "Yes,
>> it's been weaponized by Israel." You've
heard the term compromat, you know,
using pictures and using information to
blackmail, you know, for for political
purposes. This is something people
should know.
>> And they're openly admitting that this
is a project of Israel as compromat for
many politicians here in the West. Got
Bill Bill Gates isn't a politician, but
he's in there. Bill Clinton, you know,
Donald Trump, Elon Musk,
>> JC, [laughter]
>> I'm surprised he didn't go to Diddy's
one.
>> Diddy was doing his own thing in it.
>> Yeah, he was in the competitor.
>> Absolutely. Coke and Pepsi. [laughter]
>> That's why he's not on the files. He had
his own thing going on.
>> He was offended. He was offended that
there was a competitor. [laughter]
>> He had his own files, isn't it?
>> Yes, the Diddy Files.
>> Absolutely.
>> I'm sure Elon Musk is probably on those
as well, actually.
>> I wouldn't be surprised. I wouldn't be
surprised. That's why he was he was
putting all these memes on stuff like
that about Diddy
>> and that was a week ago he was putting
the memes
>> and now this week
>> it's it's emerged that he's part of the
Epstein files. He's the same guy who put
up a thing saying that Donald Trump is
on the Epstein files. Okay, but he's now
on the Epstein files. So what you've got
to say about that? And even if you look
strategically when it comes to politics,
a lot of people are saying maybe Trump
hasn't acquiesed to bombing Iran as
quickly as they wanted him to and that's
why this has been kind of put forward.
Why is it that anytime the American
politicians and the higherups get any
chance? They're always saying Israel,
Israel, Israel. I thought it was make
America great again.
>> That's right. And do you know what else
I found interesting talking about making
countries great again was there was um
there was a document in the Epistan
files that was talking about Turkey
>> and just a month ago I think maybe six
weeks ago I don't can't remember when
exactly I went but I went to Turkey
>> and maybe it was more than that actually
and I made this point to the Turkish
audience that doing da in Turkey in
Istanbul in these and Ankara and the
places where it really matters is not
just important as a matter of spreading
Islam, but it's actually politically
important. And one of the the most
important revelations I would say for us
as conservative Muslims that came out of
the Epsilon files
>> was that they were making a deal out of
the conservative strand of Islam or
conservative Islam becoming a bigger
thing now in Turkey. So they've
recognized that there's been a change in
Turkey for the better and they don't
want that to continue which shows us the
importance of da because these are the
elites in the society essentially.
talking about what matters most. They
spoke about the FA and they even spoke
about Lawrence Krauss.
>> Hams also had a debate with him, you
know, and it was the most watched debate
in um English speakaking language
atheist Muslim debate in in history, I
think. I don't there's been one like it
formal debate. And that debate, you
know, Krauss was in the in the Epstein
files essentially um saying something
like, you know, I've got a lot of people
to apostate from Islam. So they're all
work working for the same cause. You can
see the
>> Wasn't he the one that said that it's
okay for you to have intercourse with
your your brother or sister if you're
using protection?
>> You know, it fits in the hands and the
glove of the policies of Epstein and and
Elon Musk's family tradition actually.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And in fact, even you
mentioned Lawrence Krauss, Richard
Dawkins was pictured with Epstein.
>> Yes.
>> Even uh Ste Steven Hawking, [laughter]
>> what was he going to be doing? Even the
RA I mean
>> was an impotent man.
>> Well, apparently not. He had surrounded
by women and apparently he was going but
these are the same people saying that
there is no God. These are the same
people saying that we can derive our own
morality and you know the we don't need
God and God is dead and you know we are
just chemical scum. You know Steven
Hawking he said we are chemical scum
>> uh orbiting a you know a standard planet
in a standard solar system. It's not a
big deal.
>> Yes. Well, I think bro, you know, on
that point, you know, if you look at who
is on that list,
>> it's a mixture of anti-Islam people.
>> People who are working politically
against Islam, socially against Islam,
etc., etc., etc. You don't really find
there is no conservative Muslims who are
promoting conservative Islamic causes
that are on that list. Alhamdulillah.
That's a great thing.
>> I mean, these people always talk about
like how many Nobel Prize winners do we
have. We may not be on the Nobel Prize
winners list that's selected by the
elites, but we're also not on lists like
this, which is a great thing as well,
right? Um having said that look it shows
us that without religion without firm
belief in the purpose of life which is
to worship Allah subhana wa ta'ala the
elites their best guys the guys who are
meant to be their smartest the guys that
are meant to be their cleverest the guys
that meant to be their most successful
financially technologically politically
and otherwise those guys are actually
the most hedonistic the most depraved
the most unprincipled the most barbaric
>> the most I mean repugnant. I can't even
imagine to be honest. I find it
untenable that these people who like
Trump and Musk didn't know that there
were underage people there being abused
and trafficked. I I find that
incredulous. He said, "How could it be
that this
>> this this island was designed for that
purpose?" And you you're such a clever
man. You created this rocket here that
you were bragging about in the Epson
files. You're the president of the
United States or then became a president
of the United States. You're this,
you're that, you guys are all this. And
you haven't done due diligence on this
particular island.
>> It's nonsense. It's nonsense.
>> And you didn't have you didn't hear any
rumors of there being and this guy was
like for example in the discussion with
Elon Musk in the email discussion the
Epstein was making a point about how
young the um the subjects were.
>> Yeah.
>> They're all under a certain age. I can't
remember what age it was. So clearly
there's there's an emphasis on youth.
there's, you know, there's an emphasis
on the young uh people that he's
bringing into the island, etc. So, I how
could that not be a red flag for someone
who and he wants to go and let loose
there? He does, you know, Musk, just
like his father let loose on his sister,
whatever it was that he let loose on
that.
>> I mean, the one that
>> his own daughter,
>> the the one that I saw, he was trying to
kind of appease uh Epstein and trying to
get on the on the on the island and
Epstein wasn't really having it. M
>> he was saying you know just he told his
secretary you know just just tell him
I'm busy or something like that and then
she responds by going you know what
Epstein's very busy and you know it's uh
so that was one of the interactions
obviously we don't know what happened
after that but that it's just
embarrassing he's trying to
>> he's trying to chummy up to this
individual he's the one who's supposed
to be a genius how is this genius not
able to tell that this is a very
nefarious individual that has very
negative um intentions.
>> Well, they're all unsavory and
unpleasant characters, frankly.
>> But you know what's interesting is
people's reactions to the Epstein files.
>> I saw one of them um one of them reacted
by going, "Yeah, got to admit Epstein's
got aura." [laughter]
>> Sky News, they actually go, "It's not
really bad
>> if your name, you know, is on the
Epstein files."
>> Really?
>> Yeah. And Sky we know is owned by Rupert
Murdoch and Rupert Murdoch
>> probably on the file himself.
>> You know what I mean?
>> Is he on the file himself?
>> Wouldn't be surprised.
>> But his connections with Israel is very
strong. His connections with Trump, I
mean he's got his fingers in a lot of
pies. And Daily Mail, what did they do?
Oh, they blamed Russia. I mean, it's
just it's laughable. It's laughable the
reaction that people are having.
>> Was Putin on the Epstein list?
>> I don't think so. [laughter]
>> Even worse.
that it goes to show that the people
that are like you got the Norway leader
and this and that all sorts of stuff
going on and they're within the group.
>> But that's I mean George Carlin made a
very you know there's a very famous
quote of his saying
>> it's a big club and you ain't in it.
[laughter]
>> That's basically what Epstein was
indicating to Musk. If anything, Musk
was showing his he's his begging. He was
pleading and grling at Epstein and
Epstein, he seemed to think that this
man was a individual. Actually,
>> is that what he said?
>> Something there was something about him
saying about I don't
know who said it to whom, but
>> well, it just shows that Elon Musk has
been compensating for a very long time.
He bought an entire social media
platform. he you know let loose this
whole well reignited the whole grooming
debate just so when the time came
attention would be taken off him but
it's made no difference people are
taking him to the cleaners on his own
very platform
>> and it it shows you that that if you
don't have a life with Allah with the
purpose of life as the center of it an
anchorage a solid anchorage that you can
say that you're living for this is it
doesn't matter how much money you have.
It doesn't matter what what people you
who you know. It doesn't know what
connections you have. It doesn't matter
what rocket you think you have invented.
He he hasn't invented anything actually.
His teams that he's hired,
>> right? It doesn't matter whatever you
think you've done, whatever success you
think you got. You're going to be an
empty person because purpose can only be
achieved through the spiritual. but can
only be achieved through a connection
with Allah subhanana wa ta'ala the
creator of the heavens and the earth the
one who put human beings in this planet
for a purpose to worship him and he sent
prophets and messengers a full time
including Abraham and Moses and Jesus
and the prophet Muhammad the final
prophet if someone believes in that then
they will be saved if someone believes
in that they will be given happiness in
this dunya and in the or the hereafter
as well in this world and in the
hereafter you know and that's what Allah
says that whoever believes in Allah from
a man or a woman
we will make him live a good life and
you know what the icing on the cake is
>> that this has now literally this was the
last nail on the coffin of Israel
>> Israel simply cannot
win the PR war they have incurred had so
much damage first with genocide and now
with the Epstein blackmail files
>> and and and finally the grooming thing
is officially dead now. I mean they
imagine imagine Tommy Robinson the far
right or Elon Musk comes out and talks
about Islamic grooming gangs.
>> It's they can't do it anymore.
>> So like you know what I find it's always
the case Yeah. that there are people out
there that talk about something so much.
It's usually um an overcompensation
due to a psychological projection,
right? So they have their own feeling
about something. They're guilty and
every as we say every accusation is a
confession, right?
>> They're guilty of something and they
want to be a it's like a confession box.
So they deflect it on somebody else.
This is psychoanalysis 101, right? And
in this case, they've used the Muslim
community as a scapegoat. And you know
when the whole grooming thing happened,
you can search this up. The headlines
that say 500 mosques come together to
condemn the grooming cases. Yeah. And
the whole grooming scandal.
>> But he's Jewish.
>> There are
>> there's not even one rabbi that's come.
>> You know what I mean? Like there's no
mass condemnation of the genocide.
There's no mass condemnation of the
Epstein fire.
>> That's why it shows you the strategy
should not be defensive. The strategy
should be attacking. Like for example,
last week, last week when they did the
thing, I did a couple of clarifications
and we went back straight on the attack.
And that was much better than say I'm
defending I didn't say this and I didn't
say that and they want us to do that.
>> Let's go after them because we have
numbers. Muslim people have numbers and
social media. We can go after them and
we can cause havoc for them and that's
what we're going to do. And with that
we'll conclude witham.
Your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a masid, a
da center. This center, this masid, this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light [music] calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam. So give generously and Allahel
will give you even more.